[MUSIC PLAYING]
One word that's the bane of
both the novice and expert
programmer alike: threads.
I'm Joanna Smith and threading
can be one of the greatest
perf improvements you make,
but it will also likely
drive you crazy.
Tom Sawyer illustrated threading
perfectly a long time ago
when he needed to
paint that fence.
Because when you've got a
large chunk of work to do
and it's the same work
over and over again,
you call on some friends
to get it done quickly.
So for computations that
are taking a long time,
consider calling in
reinforcements with threads.
By allowing multiple
threads of execution
to operate on your
data set in parallel,
you reduce the overall time
required to complete the task.
With Android, threading
becomes especially important
because the entire app runs
on the main thread, which
is also called the UI thread
because it updates the UI.
And when the UI
stops responding,
users stop using your app.
So when you want to perform
some complex action in response
to a button being
pushed, for example,
you'll want to move
that off the main thread
until it is finished so that the
user can continue to interact
with your app, because
there are few things worse
than the dreaded
"application not responding" dialog.
However, integrating
threads into your system
is not for the faint of heart.
You're going to have to
rethink your entire approach
to computational complexity
and to your memory model
in order to properly
integrate threads.
So to avoid the
rabbit hole, take
advantage of the
Android framework
which has been built
to help you out.
Careful thought and planning
about your app structure
and flow will enable
you to determine
whether a thread should affect
the UI or be entirely hidden.
APIs like AsyncTask and Thread
both help you manage the work
and keep your app from hanging.
But AsyncTask will
also allow you
to affect the UI
like when you want
to display a progress dialog.
So take a walk
through your own app
and see if there are places
where it stops responding
or gets exceptionally slow
in response to a user action.
And then, move all of that
extra work off the main thread,
but, you know, thoughtfully.
Don't just change
things willy-nilly.
Because while threading
may be intimidating,
it shouldn't scare you.
What is scary though is bad
performance, which is why you
should check out the rest of
our Android Performance Patterns
content and consider joining
our G+ community for tips,
tricks, and help.
But most importantly, keep
calm, profile your code
and always remember,
perf matters!
[MUSIC PLAYING]